there are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves
eco styler is the brand of gel i use all
the time and i never knew it had this
unicorn glitter gel it's a translucent
pink color with blue iridescent sparkles
it's so pretty running this through my
hair i feel like you don't really get
the glittery effect it just kind of
tinted my hair this bluish color which
is cool just not what i thought it was
gonna look like i definitely saw the
glitter and color better when i applied
it to brushed back straight hair i think
this is cute for a little glitter moment
every once in a while and it actually
washed out of my hair easily i don't
know if you guys know this but i'm a
nail polish freak so when i saw do by
ginsoon going viral i bought it
immediately this is a milky white polish
it's very sheer and soft my nails are
super stained right now so i was worried
about how it was looking after the first
coat but when i went in with that second
coat it looked really pretty and my
nails looked so much better it was a
little streaky in the first coat but the
second went on totally smooth i do wish
though that this had a flat paddle brush
instead of this brush just to make it
easier to paint i'm sure you could find
a really good drugstore dupe for this
polish because it is on the pricey side
but i really like it this is the new
urban decay vice lip bond glossy liquid
lipstick so you get the glossiness of a
lip gloss and the wear of a liquid
lipstick this is extremely pigmented i
was really impressed by the color but i
feel like it wasn't as shiny as i
thought it would be i let it dry down
for 10 minutes and kiss the back of my
hand to see if it transferred at all and
it did but only a little bit and the
lipstick still looked good it's actually
very similar to the maybelline vinyl ink
lip color i tried a while ago so i would
probably recommend that one since it's
cheaper and performs the same i'm not a
pot concealer kind of person but i was
really excited to try out this rem
beauty sweetener concealer i also got
the dream cloud blender to test out as
well i scooped some up and just warmed
it on the back of my hand then i used my
fingers to apply everywhere i wanted to
conceal the concealer looks thicker than
it feels i was actually surprised at how
lightweight it felt when i was blending
it out the coverage with this is amazing
i was so shocked at how much it covered
up you don't need a lot at all i
definitely put too much on but i really
really like this they also included a
black and white shade in this concealer
so you can lighten your shade or deepen
it which is cool i also really like this
little sponge but it's not worth 15
these nyx ultimate glow shots look so
pretty that i literally bought three of
them they're supposed to be brightening
and give a really glowy effect although
these are gorgeous in the tube they're
just really inconsistent on the eyes the
pigment on some is better than others
but overall i would say the pigment
isn't great with these on their own i
had to build them up a lot to get them
to look like this they definitely work
better as a topper over other eye
shadows i'm so torn on these because
they look so good but it takes a lot of
work to get them that way